let's talk about the story from
timcast.com female swimmer Riley Gaines
assaulted by trans activists while
speaking on women's rights this is proof
that women need sex protected spaces the
video is crazy the video is absolutely
nuts let me let me uh let me play this
video for you
is there any uh I'll just I'll just full
size it
is there audio or what
there was when I saw oh you know what
the issue is there's a
oh wait there it is the issue is that I
haven't muted
nope still no audio wait it's still
muted
there we go and now it's on the wrong
Channel we're bad at this audio thing
you guys
[Applause]
I don't think uh
having been on the ground and actually
seen this stuff I don't think people
realize what it's like when a mob forms
and comes after you it is freaking crazy
but let me explain something
here's how it's going to go down for you
in your city
you are going to be at a grocery store
or something
or restaurant
and someone's going to overhear you
talking to your friend saying something
like yo these BLM people are nuts
they're going crazy and there's going to
be some waitress or what person who
hears you they're going to find out who
you are they're going to see your name
and they're going to find out where you
work things like that happened 10 years
ago it it things like that have happened
five years ago
one day they're going to start posting
online they're going to attack you and
your company is going to be like I don't
know what it is you did or who you talk
to but we cannot have this heat so we're
gonna have to let you go I don't know
who you pissed off or why you're gonna
be like I didn't do anything I don't
know what's going on I'm like well hey
look man we don't want to be involved in
whatever is you believe and your
ideologies don't fit this company
they're going to go to your house
they're going to protest your house
because this is what happened in
Wisconsin does anybody know why they
went to that guy's house and protested
he was some random local guy made no
sense
here's what happens
the mob there is no individual who
decides we are going to storm into this
person's house and kill them what
happens is the mob is just moving
amorphously one person steps out in
front everyone steps out in One
Direction they go to the house and one
person goes up and starts knocking on
the door as soon as that person goes on
the porch it's an invitation to the rest
of the mob to go on the porch the person
knocking then someone sneaks by and
tries to jiggle the handle someone sees
the handle jiggle and then they pop the
handle and push the door open another
person sees the door go open and then
they push their they stick their head
and look around another person sees that
person start sticking their head and say
I guess I'll go in too all of a sudden
now these people are walking into your
house all being egged on by each other
the snowflake doesn't blame itself for
the Avalanche this is how I've seen all
riots form
there will be a large group of people
one guy one antifa guide will take a
water bottle and just throw it straight
up in the air the moment that bottle
comes down then a bunch of people see
the splatter and then they start
throwing things too they're like oh
people are throwing things they throw
things
so one step at a time one person moves
an inch another person moves an inch
further and then before you know it
they've kicked your door in they're
rampaging through your house they're
smashing stuff and then once they go
into your room one guy wearing a mask
punches you in your bed and then someone
else sees it and also they're jumping up
and down in your room stomping on things
and smashing things there's kids there's
videos I know but there's like 14 year
olds listening they're gonna be having
nightmares man we got to be careful I
know it's it is true that you got to be
safe you got to take care of yourself
but you can
yeah get out of cities because what I
just described there's actually a video
of right now where people are sitting at
a restaurant and a mob of people are
standing on top of the of the restaurant
tables kicking the patrons in the face
and stomping on them I'm not just
describing something out of the blue I'm
explaining videos that have happened and
the guy in his house when the mob showed
up that mob had set fire to a different
house in Wisconsin twice and so this guy
Brandis is a shotgun through the window
and then puts it down the police come
and arrest him
well I think he's just describing the
the nature of kind of a mob Dynamic not
necessarily trying to scare uh 14 year
olds but I think that this also goes on
the inverse for the people that are out
there in the streets that are protesting
because the the gentleman in the
Boogaloo boys I forget his name right
now but the guy that had the AKA or
whatever it was
um you know if you're gonna put yourself
in that situation you're also putting
yourself in tremendous danger because if
you have if you're a member of the mob
and people are are all moving towards
you in a wave well then if someone's
armed and they fear for their lives you
don't know what might happen and maybe
that guy had no ill intentions maybe you
know as he's approaching the car maybe
he's genuinely trying to subdue or calm
the situation but you just don't know so
I I agree with Tim I mean if if I think
a really good litmus test is look at the
outflow population of your state from
2020 to 2021 if you had harsh lockdowns
you probably already had a net outflow
and those people are going to be the
people that vote in alignment with your
belief systems so it means that your
state is now so hard blue you're
probably never going to have political
power in that state again and this is
why I fled California well then one
thing that scares me with the Riley
Gaines video and how she was going to
schools and trying to speak and they're
like the mob was after her is the fact
that how many times did we grow up
hearing you know the idea that well you
know those are because college kids have
been doing this for many decades of
course however it seems like it's the
intensity and the frequency is only
getting worse however the idea was that
these kids will graduate they'll get out
into the real world and then the real
world will somehow make them normal
functioning adults but no we haven't
seen that because now we've seen these
kids will graduate and they will bring
that with them to their workplaces I
think the New York Times ran appease the
other year I think it was last year
right that Millennials are now afraid or
older Millennials are afraid of genzirs
who are coming along because you might
be 38 39 thinking that you're you know
you're quite liberal and stuff yourself
you're more liberal than your parents
but now and you don't even know what's
coming exactly the 23 year old will kid
comes in and he thinks that you are a
microaggressor that you are XYZ and and
this is what Vivek ramaswamy said when I
interviewed him today for the culture
War podcast that a lot of people thought
the uh exactly explained it but the AI
monster was going to be a cyborg with
laser eyes but it's Dylan Mulvaney it is
these young people who have been
manipulated by the AI and it's not
intentional but it's turned them into
something out of sync with with with
human civilization with American
civilization
these people live in a world crafted by
social media algorithms they are driven
to do things that they think will be
perceived as popular they are
weak-willed individuals
and this is leading to people believing
in saying things adopting insane
behaviors and engaging in extremely
violent tactics and sometimes they end
up writing code to make the AI let me
ask right it makes it worse one thing
that that is supplemental to the AI
ideological Takeover in 2000 August of
2011 Barack Obama included in a
executive order that you would have
every single federal governmental
Department would Implement a Dei
Department within their institution so
that was the beginning of the end in
terms of having any and keeping in mind
the federal government is the number one
the largest employer in this country so
they were really like the first shot
across the bow in terms of including
diversity Equity inclusion hiring and
firing practices which is really the
woke takeover of the business World
naturally because so much of the
government's contracts are with actual
Private Industry but they also will now
in include uh demands that they also
have a Dei department so in a matter of
about 12 years you went from this
concept being almost unheard of to being
everywhere is it that the government is
not I assume they can't make private
companies start up a department but are
they just saying we're not going to be
funding it's not so actually because you
can include as a requirement in your
government contracts that you will only
do businesses business with just like
the the uh I think it was the OSHA
vaccine mandate they were saying if you
are doing business with a government uh
contractor well they're going to have to
have the Mandate as well because that's
where the money's coming from it's
taxpayer money so they can still put the
same sort of requirements it's not force
but it's saying we won't do business
with you if you don't have this they
can't literally storm your offices and
demand this one be the DI room but they
can't say we won't we won't give you
money and therefore you can't operate
you can't pay your employees you'll
close down if we are the main source of
income we're your biggest client then
you're stuck very coerced that's that's
a really great point that you bring up
because on my show I had a Firearms
expert kind a guest and so he would be
able to explain this better than I can
I'll try and like we reinforce or kind
of boil down what he was saying he's
from amaland John Crump so you know
shout out to Sean Crump but he was
saying with one of Biden's recent
executive orders mid-march how the idea
was because the the the the the dod I
think it is because they work so much
with Firearms manufacturers that to put
the squeeze on regular you know law
abiding citizens who want to buy guns
they'll tell you know the gun
manufacturer well if you want our
contract and look how much money we can
give you well then you can't sell XYZ
Bingo Firearms are accessories to
civilians and that's how they get you so
I think it's kind of similar to what you
were saying it's social emotional
learning is taking over Academia and the
education system diversity Equity
inclusion is taking over Corporate
America as well as obviously
governmental departments and then you
have ESG which is taking over the
highest levels of Finance those are the
three evil acronyms that are taking over
everything you spoke to the vet today
I'm sure he would agree do you think
that there's uh that the market will
correct itself it's very tough because
what you're competing with is a is a
printing press-backed
mechanism you have you have access to
not just the law setting but the setting
of the interest rates plus the setting
of of uh you know monetary Supply thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time